Tom I never thought I would be
discussing Kate Upton's Twitter rant
with you but we are because she she was
defending her boyfriend but I said let's
let's move that to the side here does
she have a point in what she said about
Justin Verlander not getting the Scion
uh she does have appointed there's two
different arguments here first of all
Verlander wins the popular vote loses
the election where we heard that once
before at second of all let's put aside
the two ballots in Tampa Bay that did
not have him listed because I'm assuming
that those guys did not you know there
may be more considering him at the
bottom of their ballot you know the
fourth or fifth spots if they put him on
their ballots and fourth or fifth he
still doesn't win so what it came down
to is the fact the second place votes
Porcello had 18 of them and Justin only
had two of them not to me he didn't get
robbed only because I think Porcello
Verlander Kluber I mean they're all
worthy of winning and I I don't say that
quick to this late I really thought it
was a coin flip but you have a 3-sided
coin and either one could one so it
wasn't like he got robbed but what it
tells us did when you look at the voting
pretty look at the voting like politics
baseball writers voting is really local
because you look at the where the votes
are coming for these guys and it was
within their own divisions is the system
does it need to be revamped uh no I
don't think it needs to be revamped
we've gone to full transparency you know
unlike the Hall of Fame voting we know
exactly who's voting and exactly what
their ballots are in this case one
through five and we'll get it one
through ten in the MVP tonight so I
think there is transparency that's all
you could ask for um and I don't think
it needs to be revamped I think yeah if
you're looking to revamp it one thing
you may consider and I thought about
this in my head I'm not sure I've got
all this way have more people vote you
know the baseball writers we have just
about everybody voting on the hall of
fame but it comes down to these seasonal
awards and you're talking about only 30
writers out of a few hundred we're
voting on the award so you could expand
it like the Heisman voting they
got it right with Max Scherzer in the
nationally yeah I think so i was
surprised though that he won by as much
as he did um you know the voters really
love power pitching and unfortunate
it'll work out for Justin but the
strikeouts I thought for Scherzer put
him over the top um interesting that
Kyle Hendricks got left off of him about
himself and nobody noticed that yeah
yeah MVP voting uh what do you think
how's that play out well I think Bryant
is going to win fairly easily I be
shocked that would be a big upset if
Murphy or Seager won a National League
American League vote to me is
fascinating then it gets back to the 0
argument about can you be valuable on a
team that basically didn't play
meaningful games the whole year of
course that's Mike Trout and the angels
I think you certainly can when you're as
good as Mike Trout when you're that far
much better than the field and he was
this year but I have a feeling the
voters will still put a value on guys
you play for postseason team and that
points the dial to set now look at his
lineup man he has a lot of help in that
lineup you know you could make a case
for David Ortiz's an MVP Pedroia had a
great year and Hanley Ramirez out and on
and on not taking anything away from
Mookie but there's no help there from
Mike Trout I mean Mike Trout is the best
player in baseball I think we all know
that I think he a year that proved it I
don't think he's going to win if I had a
vote on that one band I'd probably give
it to Mike Trout because I think he was
that much better than everybody else but
based on voting history I I would lean
towards bets actually winning it I don't
know if you sold his story Sweeney
murdie who covers the Yankees for WFAN
in New York said a baseball scout told
him that the Yankees are trying to get
enough pieces together to make a deal go
after Mike Trout what do you make of
that this is true too that some
legitimacy to that and start with this
it would've been impossible for the
Yankees 12 months ago even think about
that but they really have restocked
their system and and done a really good
job trades with Chapman and Miller and
some of the other guys they moved and
they're talking about prospects now who
are at major league-ready or close not
just lottery tickets down on a ball
so I think they would have the
wherewithal to have something that's
tempting to the angel and Brian
Cashman's old assistant Billy Eppler is
out there running the angels but I don't
see the angels trading lecture I really
don't I mean he's everything you want in
a franchise player the minute you trade
him the minute you're hoping someone
else can get even close to him I think
he's the most valuable commodity in
baseball and may I know they're got a
long way to go before they turn things
around what they're going nowhere
without Mike Trout I just don't think
you could go into the history books as
the guy who traded my chrome agree with
that I mean even if you quote unquote
win the deal the winds not going to show
up for a year yeah I when I look at the
Yankees man I look I think they're more
gearing up to making a run at Bryce
Harper on the free agent market you know
as they start to infiltrate the younger
guys in the lineup I'll have cost saving
that's more money coming up with folks
up to this year I think this sort of
where the cubs were a couple of years
ago where it's probably not 2017 where
they really can't end it's probably 2018
and then after that they'll have a lot
of money to go after Bryce Harper will
the Cubs look the same next season not
really to me Dexter Fowler is the key I
think you could have a really good
market may not be back which may have to
slide his aorta center maybe Albert
Almora plays there we know Hamels god
Mike Montgomery is going to go in the
rotation listen the average major league
team turns over thirty percent every
year so you're not going to bring the
entire roster back even have to go in
the World Series but in terms of their
cord end yeah I mean I think we'll look
that possibility to be where the Yankees
were late 90s I'm not saying they're
going to run off you know three in a row
in terms of World Championships but
playing for World Series titles yeah
they should be playing for multiples in
the next four or five years thank you
Tom I'll let you know when I get
something from kate upton again that we
can discuss wait let me know all right
now that's Tom Verducci senior Baseball
Writers Sports Illustrated the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you